i'm the one who reacts breaking bad
medical scenes here we go huge thanks to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video
what
the hell is this hey veggie bacon we're
watching our cholesterol i guess not me
want real bacon
this feels like my struggle right now
because i'm watching my cholesterol it's
more about decreasing the amount of
saturated fat in your diet decreasing
fatty foods fried foods and also at the
same time increasing your insoluble
fiber
[Music]
[Music]
oh no don't paint don't be
if you're ever feeling lightheaded the
first thing you should do is get down on
the floor the biggest danger of passing
out is actually hitting your head and
causing a subdural hemorrhage so please
if you're feeling woozy get down get
support call for help this is so
embarrassing i am fine honestly
it's just some bug going around first my
wife had it then my son and now me it's
just
it's just like a
chest cold see it's important to not
minimize your symptoms is it possible
that he has a chest cold sure but why in
the world did he pass out from standing
that needs to be further investigated
and it needs to be investigated by an er
team because he could be having a heart
attack for all they do lean forward for
me would you
[Applause]
mr white are you a smoker
no
never
why do you ask
okay this is where these shows things
get a little ridiculous the paramedic
with the power of a stethoscope can
diagnose that there's some really
serious issue going on like lung cancer
at most you can hear lung sounds that
can happen as a result of a pneumonia of
a viral infection an inflammatory
process a tumor but you can't know that
without scanning so this like devious
mischievous look of him going
by listening with the stethoscope is
pure ridiculous
[Music]
mr
[Music]
mr white
yes
you understood what i've just said to
you
yes
lung cancer inoperable i'm really glad
they're showing this part when you're
receiving bad news it's really difficult
to comprehend you just got a diagnosis
that you're potentially sick for the
rest of your life we're gonna lose your
life earlier than you expected you're
not gonna be okay so what are the next
steps of what i should do so whenever
you deliver bad news as a doctor you
have to have the patient come back you
have to have someone with the patient to
help them understand what's going on
this part could be the most accurate
part of the first season lung cancer
inoperable i also don't know how they
realize that it's inoperable so quickly
a little bit out there i don't know how
much time has passed here it's it's a
little inaccurate it's just
you've got mustard
on your
this is almost like a dissociation
process where to escape from the bad
news he's reverting back to like a
childhood state or a less serious state
and thinking about the mustard because
that's more fixable in the given moment
this does happen maybe this is a little
bit more exaggerated though
heisenberg says relax
i'm relaxed
i'm relaxed i'm electric oh
damn man look at that look i'm not
surprised if he broke a few knuckles
hitting a skull on the floor like that
over and over again remember when you
punch someone standing up their head
moves back so there's no excess force
placed on your knuckle in your boat but
when they're laying down and you're
hitting them you're essentially hitting
the concrete with your bare knuckle
you're breaking stuff
how's it bark
what's the matter with you
looks like he's having a seizure
sometimes that can happen with brain
bleeds
there's there's no uh a pulse
after there's no pulse you gotta start
chest compression chest compression
chest compression do something
do something he he needs an ambulance he
needs a hospital do something you're
smart right do not do that thing he
knows that thing but the thing is really
meant to buy you time it doesn't
actually restart the heart the point of
doing the thing is so that the ambulance
has time to get there and actually
intervene
beans
castor beans
so what are we gonna do with them we are
going to process them into ricin you
actually process it into castor oil and
the residue has ricin in it rice and
beans
ricin he said rice and beans i forgot
about this it's an extremely effective
poison it's toxic in small doses also
fairly easy to overlook during an
autopsy it is checked for an autopsies
by the way especially if there is a
suspicious cause of death back to more
breaking bad in just a second but first
i want to talk to you about nordvpn it's
a service that protects your internet
connection and privacy online one of the
best things about nordvpn is that it
secures your traffic on public wi-fi
which keeps things like your account
logins and banking info safe and not
only that but you can run it up to six
devices at once on every major platform
nordvpn also gives you access to content
from anywhere say you're in a country
that doesn't have a streaming option for
breaking bad you can use nordvpn set
your location to a country that does
have access to breaking bad and stream
as much as you want it's so easy and
just takes one click go to
nordvpn.com dr mike and use coupon code
dr mike just remember doctors spelled
out to save 73 on a two-year plan plus
one month free all right let's get back
to more breaking bad
[Music]
this is fugue state what's the last
thing you remember
uh well i
was driving home
i think
from what i remember he's faking this
and he's doing a really good job isn't
it
possible that this had something to do
with all the prescriptions i've been
taking in order to diagnose a medication
side effect like that it really has to
be a diagnosis of exclusion where you
rule everything else out that could
cause this dissociative state of his and
then you can then blame the medication
but you absolutely do need a psychiatric
consult here would you tell me about
patient confidentiality
it's very straightforward without your
permission i can't disclose anything you
tell me to anyone what about my family
not to your family not to the police not
to anyone
the only exception would be if you
threaten to kill someone
then i'd be able to tell that person but
only that person protected health
information is really important in the
cases of homicidal or suicidal ideation
we do
alert the authorities or loved ones i
don't know that in a homicidal situation
if you threaten to harm one other person
they only tell that person i think they
have to notify the authorities as well
jesse
wake up jesse
wake up
that is a needle
and a syringe
likely to have been used for narcotics
[Music]
oh no if someone's throwing up on their
back you have to put them on their side
in order to help clear their airway
because if they can't protect their
airway because they're unconscious they
can aspirate the vomit choke die
dude you gotta act
that is unfortunately how a lot of
overdoses do end someone ends up
aspirating and choking to death
oh that's gotta hurt
that's one way to crush your femur
create a fatty embolism make it go to
your lungs and you just die instantly
also don't forget crush injuries release
a massive amount of electrolytes into
the bloodstream from the damaged cells
and create a complete mashup of your
electrical system in the body which most
importantly happens in the heart
therefore it could be lethal
[Music]
how come like bad guys in movies always
walk so calmly like they're never in a
rush
like my guy you don't think the cops are
coming after you just lit up a parking
lot
[Music]
no
we
yeah the bad guy's not in a rush
he lit up a supermarket he's not in a
rush he's getting his axe
an axe to the head is incompatible with
life
gsw to the head incompatible with life
thought i thought i'd let you guys know
no impossibly
foreign
induction of vomiting for poison can
work it has to happen very rapidly
remember ricin gets absorbed very
quickly into your mucous membranes
that's why it can affect you even
through your eyes can you make it less
lethal if you vomit it up yeah probably
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like if this was true ricin there
would be a lot of vomiting here
those are pixas machines those look very
legitimate
it's like a full operating room in there
those hospital beds are so extremely
expensive you have no idea
[Applause]
i mean you have to intubate him you have
to make sure his heart's not stopped
these are the most crucial moments in
order to help save someone's life
oh i have no idea what he just squirted
into his mouth
all right and she's bagging way too fast
when you're bagging you need to bag at
the same rate that a person would
breathe if we're at rest you're bagging
you could actually create a bigger
problem
they're doing an intubation it looks
like
some leads that aren't sticking well
starting ivs all good stuff
oh they're doing dialysis
to get rid of the poison wow
that's a blood transfusion
oh negative blood
universal donor
oh
gracias i love that he's chilling
already not realistic
[Music]
not surviving that
[Applause]
nope maybe i was wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
i love how the staff run in no concern
that there's another explosion that's
about to happen
oh okay yeah he's not fixing his tie
that's ridiculous this isn't batman
did you know that i'm a youtube boxer
now click here to check that out i
literally eat punches and give them away
huge thank you again to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video as always stay
happy and healthy first i beat when i
treat
[Music]